We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two David P.
We heard from the egg man who mostly listens to
the show, but he watched the other day and it
sounds like he kind of liked it. Take a listen.
Hey, Dave, you know, I just listened to your
podcast. I don't watch videos or YouTube or any
clips or anything. I'm an adult. I'm busy all day.
Right. I have time to listen while I work. I've
been missing out on the visual aspect. Oh, my God.
I just watched a clip on Facebook and you're
listening to some crazy caller and you take
a sip of your water with your hand underneath
the cup, like prompted. And I started cracking
up and I thought, how many other purely
visual jokes am I missing from you, Dave?
Have I been just only getting two
dimensions of three dimensional? So. Yes.
Oh, man, I've been missing out,
fellow brother, and, you know,
have a really good time off the holiday season.
Yeah. Yeah. There are many visual elements that
you were missing if you were only listening
to the show. But I understand lots of people
prefer just to listen, and that's absolutely
fine. We have the audio podcast for that reason
on the bonus show today, the U.S.
government has figured out how to
get one hundred million more vaccine
doses from Pfizer. We will discuss it.
New York is leading the nation in population
decline and they may lose two House seats as
a result. And the Texas lieutenant governor
who offered a million bucks, if you can find
evidence of voter fraud and. Is now refusing to
pay it after we found evidence of pro Trump voter
fraud happening, we covered that story yesterday.
We will discuss the follow the fallout on
today's bonus show, get instant access by
becoming a member at join Pakman Dotcom.